لا تزال أليسون حزينة على أولادها ،
حيث تم تسجيل نبضات قلبهم الصغيرة وتخزينها
داخل دمية تذكيرًا مؤلمًا
بالأرواح التي فقدوها والألم الذي تحمله القليل من
اليد وآثار الأقدام هناك ،
لذا فهمت أنه خلال السنوات الثلاث
الماضية ، حملت أليسون مرتين.
التلقيح الاصطناعي مع الحيوانات المنوية من متبرع
كان حملها الأول يسير بسلاسة حتى 25
أسبوعًا عندما قالت
إنه تم اكتشاف تشوهات كانت في اللحظة التي
يسقط فيها القاع من عالمي
بموجب القانون الأيرلندي لا يمكن إجراء الإجهاض إلا
حتى 12 أسبوعًا من الحمل
بعد ذلك  قانوني فقط إذا كانت
صحة الأم في خطر جسيم أو
إذا قرر طبيبان أن الجنين من
المحتمل أن يموت قبل أو في غضون 28 يومًا
من الولادة ، كانا متأكدين إلى حد ما من
أنه سيموت ، لكنهما لم يعرفوا
متى لا يوجد تشخيص واضح ، لم يستطع أليسون  لم
نحصل على عملية إجهاض في أيرلندا ، وأصبح الآن أمامه
قرار يتخذه إذا نجا
بسبب جميع مشاكل الدماغ ، فسيصاب
بنوبات صرع يومية متعددة.
ليس لديه
وظيفة حركية ، فلن يتمكن أبدًا من
الجلوس أو إعالة نفسه ، لذا قررت في الأسبوع الثلاثين من
الحمل السفر إلى
إنجلترا لإنهاء حملها ، فأنت
تقرر بشكل أساسي كيف
تريد أن يموت طفلك هل
تريد أن يموت  ببطء أو ترغب في
أن يموتوا بسرعة ، هذا
ما يتلخص في أنه أمر مروع لأنه
يبدو بعد عامين حزينًا على حمل
طفلها البكر أليسون مرة أخرى ،
لكنها هذه المرة تركت الحمل يسير
في مساره ، حيث يعيش الطفل لمدة
ساعة فقط.
استغرق الأمر أكثر من 35 عامًا
لتغيير دستور الجزر لإضفاء الشرعية على
الإجهاض ، ولكن كما سمعت للتو من
محنة أليسون هناك ، فإن الانتصار
كان بعيدًا عن الكمال ،
حتى النساء اللواتي يرغبن بشدة في إنجاب
الأطفال يواجهن أكثر القرارات المؤلمة
فيما يتعلق بالاستمرار في
الحمل وفقًا لذلك.  لدى حكومة المملكة المتحدة ،
سافرت أكثر من 200 امرأة من جمهورية أيرلندا إلى إنجلترا
خلال العام الماضي لإجراء عمليات إجهاض لأكثر
من نصفهن.  حد ذاتها بسبب
تشوهات الجنين التي لا يمكن اكتشافها في بعض الأحيان إلا
بعد مرور 12 أسبوعًا على تلك العلامة القانونية ،
وهي حكاية تحذيرية ربما عن الصدمة التي
قد تواجهها النساء الأميركيات لأنهن
لا يعرفن القتال في المستقبل أفضل من
المدافعة عن حقوق الإجهاض ألفا سميث
التي ساعدت في تحويل  المد من أجل
حقوق المرأة مع انتصار تاريخي في
استفتاء 2018 ،
فإن المعركة التي تقول لي لم تنته بعد ،
وعلينا الاستمرار في توسيع هذا القانون
وتحريره ، ونأمل أن يصل الإجهاض إلى الحد
الذي لن يصبح فيه الإجهاض يومًا ما
جزءًا من التشريع ولكن سيتم
دمجه فيه.  الرعاية الصحية
ولكن بينما تقول أن الجزيرة تسير أخيرًا على
الطريق الصحيح ، فإن الولايات المتحدة
أخبرتني أنها اتخذت منعطفًا خاطئًا ،
فقد فكرنا حقًا في أننا
أرض الحرية ولكن لم يعد هذا هو الحال
بعد الآن لرؤية ذلك يتم قلبه
بصراحة  حفنة من الرجال المتعصبين أمر
مخزٍ تمامًا. أطلب من أليسون أن تدلي
بأفكارها بشأن قرار المحكمة
العليا
الأمريكية.  ckward
خطوة وقلبي يخرج
من الشعور بأنه ربما فقط أولئك
الذين ساروا في هذه الرحلة ويحملون
ثقل الخسارة يمكنهم حقًا فهم
جزيرة عيسى سواريز سي إن إن دبلن